This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For the most part, we take time for granted. Maybe we don't have enough of it, but at least we know how it works. At least, you know, most of the time. A lot of what we think about time and how we keep track of it is relatively recent. And some aspects that we take for granted aren't actually all that universal. And today, we're going to be talking to a few of my 99 nine colleagues for a set of many stories about our evolving relationship with time. And to get us started, it's Kurt Colstead, the co-author of the 99% Invisible City. And in our book, we wrote about the standardization of time that came with the rise of railroads. Right. And before standard times, rail companies had to juggle all of these city-specific time zones. But there's
这里是 99% 隐秘之物。我是罗曼·马斯。大体上，我们都把时间视为理所当然。也许我们的时间不够用，但至少我们知道它是如何运作的。至少，你知道，大多数时候是这样的。我们对时间的很多看法以及我们如何记录时间，都是相对较近才有的事。而我们视为理所当然的一些方面，其实并没有那么普适。今天，我们将与我的几位 99PI 同事聊聊一系列关于我们与时间不断演变的关系的小故事。首先登场的是《99% 隐秘之城》的合著者库尔特·科尔斯特ッド。在我们的书中，我们写到了随着铁路兴起而带来的时间标准化。没错。在标准时间出现之前，铁路公司不得不应对所有这些按城市划分的时区。但特别有
one really neat artifact, in particular, from that period, which really brings the point home. So here's this old ornate clock that hangs on the facade of the Bristol corn exchange building in England. So this is a lovely clock with red letters and red hands, except for there seems to be kind of what looks like a long, black, almost like a second hand potentially, but I can't quite make sense of what it's for. Yeah, yeah, you could definitely think that's the second hand, but it's actually a second minute hand, so there are two different minute hands,
一个非常巧妙的物件，来自那个时期，它真正把这一点表达得淋漓尽致。这里有一个古老华丽的时钟，挂在英国布里斯托尔玉米交易所建筑的外墙上。所以这是一个很可爱的钟，有红色的字和红色的指针，除了似乎有一种看起来像长长的、黑色的、几乎像秒针的东西，但我不太明白它是用来做什么的。对，对，你绝对会认为那是秒针，但它实际上是第二个分针，所以有两个不同的分针，
and they're set about 10 minutes apart from each other and they're painted Those different colors so that you know people on the streets below can tell them apart. So does this second minute hand also have to do with trains Absolutely, so they have this one hand that's for Bristol and then when train travels started becoming more commonplace They added a second minute hand to show London time, and that's the one that's colored black. Got it. So one hand is for locals that they're still on the local time. The other is for people traveling in and out of the city. And presumably that the local time is based on high noon when they sun is highest in the sky. That's what we talk about in the book. How did they get this London time that showed here in this picture about 10 minutes off?
它们之间相差大约 10 分钟，并且涂成了不同的颜色，以便下面街道上的人们能够区分它们。那么这个第二个分针也跟火车有关吗？绝对的，它们有一个是指示布里斯托尔时间的指针，然后当火车旅行变得越来越普遍时，他们添加了第二个分针来显示伦敦时间，那就是涂成黑色的那个。明白了。所以一个指针供本地人使用，他们仍然在使用地方时间。另一个供进出该市的旅客使用。据推测，本地时间是根据正午太阳在天空中最高的时候确定的。这就是我们在书中讨论的内容。他们是如何得到这张照片中显示的这个大约相差 10 分钟的伦敦时间的呢？
Right, so that's the crazy part. Apparently, they actually sent people out from London on trains with these precisely tuned watches. And so that way they could keep clocks like this one up to date on London time. So the railroad used the train network to keep track of time. Yeah, it's sort of this weird meta phenomenon. And so you have these dedicated time keepers who would arrive in a given town and then they'd hop off the train and they'd go show their watch to the station master because
对，这才是最疯狂的部分。显然，他们实际上派人从伦敦乘火车带着这些精确调校的手表出发。通过这种方式，他们可以使像这个时钟这样的时钟与伦敦时间保持同步。所以铁路部门利用铁路网来追踪时间。是的，这有点像那种奇怪的元现象。所以你有这些专门的计时员，他们会到达某个特定的城镇，然后他们会跳下火车，去向车站长展示他们的手表，因为
the local railroad operators needed to know the precise time in London. And then those same watch wearing travelers would hop on to another train to a different city and so on and so forth. And they go about basically updating clocks all across the country, one station at a time. That is wild. Imagine all these people riding around just to set blocks. I was like, like everyone's like a cog in their own clock. Yeah, it's great. They're just parts of a machine.
当地的铁路运营商需要知道伦敦的精确时间。然后那些戴着手表的旅客会跳上另一列开往不同城市的火车，以此类推。他们基本上是在全国各地更新时钟，一个车站接一个车站地进行。这太疯狂了。想象一下所有这些人到处跑只是为了对准时钟。我就像，就像每个人都是自己时钟里的一个齿轮。太棒了。他们只是机器的一部分。
That's hilarious. Yeah, I love it. I love it so much. And it's so hard for us, you know, today to wrap our minds around the way it was, but really, like up until that point, local time was just the time. And so that's just how people went about their days. And a lot of folks were pretty reluctant to get on board with these new fangled ideas like standard time. So really this like three hennet clock is a relic of that brief moment in time between the old and new when there was an acceptance that standard time was kind of required in some ways,
这太搞笑了。是的，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。对于我们今天的人来说，要理解当年的那种方式是如此困难，但真的，直到那个时候，地方时间就是时间。所以人们就是这样度过他们的日子的。很多人对于接受标准时间这种新奇的想法相当排斥。所以这个三指针时钟实际上是新旧交替之间那个短暂时刻的遗物，当时人们一方面认为某种程度上标准时间是必须的，
but local time was still preferred. And you were just like in this weird interregnum where both of those things were equally dominant. Yeah, that's exactly it. What struck me in writing about this transition is that railroads really effectively collapsed both space and time. What do I mean by that? Well, they made longer journeys go faster, right?
但地方时间仍然是首选。你就像处于这样一个奇怪的过渡期，这两者同样占据主导地位。对，就是这样。在书写这段过渡期时，最触动我的是铁路确实有效地压缩了空间和时间。我这是什么意思？嗯，它们让更长的旅程变得更快，对吧？
But they also compressed the world into these fewer number of time zones. So suddenly you don't have hundreds of time zones for every city, you just have, you know, two dozen spanning the globe. And meanwhile, local time was this really big headache and increasingly a safety hazard for railway operators. Because if they got it wrong, even by a few minutes, trains could literally
但它们也将世界压缩到了更少数量的时区中。所以突然之间，你不再有几百个对应每个城市的时间区，你只有（你知道的）横跨全球的两打时区。与此同时，地方时间是一个非常大的头痛问题，对铁路运营商来说越来越成为一种安全隐患。因为如果他们弄错了，哪怕只有几分钟，火车也可能 literalmente
crash into each other. And of course, eventually, there were global agreements around time, and things became standardized. But I'm really fond of these quirky exceptions and these little remnants of that interstitial period, like this clock in Bristol. So what follows is a bunch of stories about the struggle of us all being on the same time together.
撞在一起。当然，最终，围绕时间达成了全球协议，事情变得标准化了。但我真的很喜欢这些奇特的例外和那个过渡时期的这些小残余，比如布里斯托尔的这个时钟。接下来是一堆关于我们所有人一起处于同一时间所经历的挣扎的故事。
Who gets left behind, what individuality gets squashed, when everyone tries to sync up and all be at the same place at the same time. So for our next time story, we're going to be talking to 99PI producer, Joe Rosenberg, hey, Joe. Hey, Roman. So what do you have for us? So for this story, we're basically
谁被抛下了，当每个人都试图同步并在同一时间出现在同一地点时，什么个性被压制了。因此，对于我们的下一个时间故事，我们将与 99PI 制作人乔·罗森伯格交谈，嘿，乔。嘿，罗曼。那么你给我们带来了什么？所以对于这个故事，我们基本上
going to start or Kurt left us off this kind of moment of transition when it comes to timekeeping in Britain. Yeah, like the rise of the regiment at one then time. Yeah, exactly. And everyone running around with watches being like, this is the time, this is it. Like, I know the time you don't get with the program,
将从库尔特离开我们的地方开始，也就是英国计时方式的这种过渡时刻。是的，就像那时的有规律的一致时间的兴起。是的， exatamente。每个人都拿着手表跑来跑去，好像在说，这就是时间，就是这个。就像，我知道时间，你如果不跟上时代，
this is the time. This is it. Like I know the time you don't get with the program. This is the time. Exactly. Because it turns out that there's this one very specific profession from around that period, the middle of the 19th century. That's a variation on that phenomenon. And out of like all of the whimsical quirky jobs that have ever existed in human history. It's now my favorite. Okay, what is it? Well, I want you to imagine that you are a factory worker and say like Manchester in the 1860s. And maybe you've moved to the city from the countryside where you were used to just getting up with the sun. You worked when it was light, you didn't when it was dark. It's pretty simple. But now you have to get up before it's even light
这就是时间。就是这个。就像我知道时间，你如果不跟上时代。这就是时间。Exactly。因为事实证明，大约在那个时期（19世纪中叶），有一个非常具体的职业。那是这种现象的一个变体。在人类历史中存在过的所有异想天开、古怪的工作中，它现在成了我最喜欢的一个。好吧，是什么？嗯，我想象你是一个工厂工人，比如 1860 年代的曼彻斯特。也许你从乡下搬到了城市，在那里你习惯了日出而作。有光的时候工作，天黑了就不工作。这很简单。但现在你必须在天亮之前起床，
because your shift at the local cotton mill starts at like 2 a.m. sharp. Hmm, yeah. So the question is, how do you do this? How do you wake up? I'm assuming there's no alarm clocks at this point. There's probably not even widespread watches for this class of people, necessarily.
因为你在当地棉纺厂的轮班大约在凌晨 2 点准时开始。嗯，对。所以问题是，你是怎么做到的？你是怎么醒来的？我假设当时没有闹钟。这一阶层的人可能甚至不一定有广泛普及的手表。
Yeah, no alarm clocks and the watches will get to. Okay. Those things, yeah, they're not cheap or widespread at the very least. So instead, the solution is that you would rely on a kind of human alarm clock by hiring a knocker upper. A knocker upper? It sounds faintly rude, really. It doesn't have out of context. But it wasn't. It was a proper job title and not a rapper. So this is Ruth Goodman. She is a UK historian and TV presenter and the author of the books How to Be a Victorian and the Domestic Revolution. Her specialty is everyday life in historical periods and she says a knocker upper was someone with a good watch, meaning back then
是的，没有闹钟，手表我们等会儿会讲到。好的，那些东西，是的，它们既不便宜也不普遍。所以相反的解决办法是，你会依靠一种人类闹钟，也就是雇佣一个叫敲窗人的人。敲窗人？这听起来有点粗鲁，真的。脱离上下文听起来确实如此。但事实并非如此。这是一个正式的职位名称，而不是说唱歌手。这位是鲁思·古德曼。她是英国历史学家、电视节目主持人，也是《如何成为维多利亚时代的人》和《家庭革命》一书的作者。她的专业领域是历史时期的日常生活，她说敲窗人是一个带着好表的人，意思是当时
an accurate watch, who would be paid a small fee by various individual residents of a working class area to wake each of them up at a particular time, depending on when their shift started. But naturally, you can't have somebody banging on the door at two o'clock in the morning, saying, wakey, wakey, wakey, loud enough to wake all the neighbors. And so the way the knocker upper would do it is they would go around with this really long fine cane and just reach up to the upper floors of buildings and lightly tap on their customers windowpains until they woke up. I can see why this is your favorite job in history. This is so delightful. I love it. Yeah, I mean, it's like the Kenzian but it but like nice, you know.
一只精准的手表，工薪阶层地区的各个居民会付给他一小笔费用，让他根据他们各自的班次开始时间，在特定时间叫醒他们每个人。但自然地，你不能让某人在凌晨两点砰砰敲门，大喊“醒醒醒醒”，声音大到足以吵醒所有邻居。所以敲窗人的做法是，他们会拿着这根非常长而细的手杖，直接够到建筑物的上层，轻轻敲击客户的窗玻璃，直到他们醒来。我能理解为什么这是你历史上最喜欢的工作了。这太令人愉快了。我太喜欢了。是的，我的意思是，这就像坎齐安（Kenzian）一样，但——但很友好，你知道的。
Exactly. And so they would just slowly go around to one address at perhaps 405 AM, tap on the upper left window, then move on to the next house at 410 AM, tap on the lower right window, and just go down their list. And always aiming, of course, to tap very gently, but not too gently. Some knocker-up ass warbline that you needed, a particular bit of something on the end of the cake,
Exactly。所以他们会慢慢地走到一个地址，也许是早上 4 点 05 分，敲敲左上方的窗户，然后在大约早上 4 点 10 分移动到下一栋房子，敲敲右下方的窗户，就这样顺着他们的名单走下去。当然，目标始终是轻轻地敲，但又不能太轻。一些敲窗人警告说，你需要
to get the right amount of noise that would wake people up in the room, but not wake people up next door. And that way, if they wanted to wake up cold, they'd also have to pay you. There's no point having one paying customer to street the whole street getting the benefit. And so here, let me show you a photo of a knucker upper applying their trade. Oh, this is great. So this is long row of houses, connected houses, row houses,
在手杖的顶端加上一点特别的东西，才能发出恰到好处的噪音，既能把房间里的人吵醒，又不会吵醒隔壁的人。这样一来，如果他们想清醒过来，他们也必须付钱给你。如果整条街只有一个付费客户，而整条街的人都沾光，那就没有意义了。所以，来，我给你看一张敲窗人正在工作的照片。哦，这太棒了。所以这是一排长长的房子，相连的房子，排屋，
and a person on the street with a cane that looks like, I don't know, maybe 15 feet long or something like that, like really something. Yeah, no, it's a solid somewhere between 15 and 20 feet longs, giant cane, just to reach up to that second floor. And you can see he's just going down this kind of classic London row house, tapping on each window. That's so great. So I see what you need to use the cane for the second floor.
街上有一个人拿着一根手杖，看起来，我不知道，也许有 15 英尺长或者类似的长度，真的很长。是的，不，这根巨型手杖实打实地介于 15 到 20 英尺长之间，只是为了能够到二楼。你可以看到他正沿着这排典型的伦敦排屋走，敲着每一扇窗户。太棒了。所以我明白为什么二楼需要用手杖了。
What do they do for the first floor? That seems kind of unnecessary. You'd be like in the middle of the street trying to reach with that thing. Yeah, so there was a few different knocking up methods. The cane was just one, depending on where your customers were and what the lay of the land was.
那对于一楼他们怎么做呢？这似乎有点没必要。你得站在街道中间，试图用那个东西去够。是的，所以有几种不同的敲窗方法。手杖只是其中之一，这取决于你的客户在哪里以及那里的地形如何。
So some people had like a mallet for ground floor doors. Others in like company towns might be hired by a mining company to very deliberately wake up everyone at the same time. And apparently those knocker uppers, since the whole point was to be as loud as possible, use like one of those wooden clackers that you would see at soccer matches. Do you know what I'm talking about? Yeah, I do, actually. But most knocker uppers, like Ruth said, found ways to be a
所以有些人有一把用于一楼门的小木槌。其他人，比如在公司小镇里，可能会被矿业公司雇佣来非常刻意地同时叫醒所有人。显然，那些敲窗人，既然重点是要尽可能声音响亮，就会使用你在足球比赛中看到的那种木制手摇铃。你知道我在说什么吗？是的，我知道，确实知道。但大多数敲窗人，正如鲁思所说，找到了更精确的方法。
little more precise. One very famous knocker rapper, she used a pea shooter and she had a little that hollow tube and she would blow dried peas with window. Wow, we know who that person is. We actually do. That apparently was Mary and Smith of East London. And there's also a really charming photo of her. Let me show you that one too. Oh my God, this is so great. So she's just there with her pea shooter, her hands in her cardigan, which I'm assuming
有一个非常著名的敲窗人，她用的是一根吹箭筒，她有一个小小的中空管子，她把干豌豆吹向窗户。哇，我们知道那个人是谁。我们确实知道。那显然是东伦敦的玛丽·安·斯密斯。而且还有一张非常迷人的她的照片。我也让你看看那张。哦，天哪，这太棒了。所以她就站在那里，拿着吹箭筒，双手插在开衫里，我猜开衫里
holds the pebbles or peas that she is shooting. Yeah, her cheeks are like puffed out. That'll be exactly, yeah. She's in mid pea shoot. That's so yeah. Like, she's in mid-P shoot. That's so good. Oh, it's so good. Yeah. It's really fascinating, the way official regiment of time is just kind of proliferating,
装着她要射出的石子或豌豆。是的，她的脸颊鼓鼓的。完全是那样，是的。她正处于吹豌豆的过程中。太好了。就像，她正处于吹豌豆的过程中。太棒了。哦，太棒了。是的。真的很迷人，那种官方规整的时间正在不断扩散，
and it hasn't quite reached into the bedroom of the working class, but it's reached just as far as their window. Yeah, and in addition to it kind of spreading practically, it was also spreading culturally in the 19th century. People were getting really into being very precise about what time it was. Ruth says it was just seen as the modern forward-thinking thing to do. And she says one fun example in her own research where she could kind of see this plane out is actually the Jack the Ripper case. Going through all those police reports was extraordinary because there they are at the end of the 19th century saying at 916 and I'm thinking 916, that's ridiculously accurate. You know, and then they're saying like in six minutes later this happened and 14 minutes
虽然它还没有完全进入工人阶级的卧室，但它已经延伸到了他们的窗户。是的，除了这种实际上的传播，它在 19 世纪也在文化上蔓延开来。人们开始对精确知道时间表现出极大的热情。鲁思说，这被视为现代的、前瞻性的做法。她说在她自己的研究中有一个有趣的例子，她可以看到这种现象的演绎，那就是开膛手杰克案。翻阅所有这些警察报告是非凡的，因为他们在 19 世纪末说，在 9 点 16 分，我想着 9 点 16 分，这准确得太离谱了。你知道，然后他们说六分钟后发生了这个，14 分钟
later that, there is no way a watch from that era could possibly be giving you quite that accuracy. And the people who was making these statements weren't even carrying watches. So the report of Jack the River, they're just making it up? Yeah, like he just heard the church bells ring maybe a quarter of an hour ago and he's just like, wing it. But he doesn't choose a nice round number. He chooses a very precise number because it lends authority to his statement. So the idea that you could be that precise was culturally enticing,
后发生了那个，那个时代的手表绝对不可能给你提供这样的准确度。而那些发表这些声明的人甚至没有随身携带手表。所以关于开膛手杰克的报告，他们是在瞎编吗？对，就像他可能只是听到教堂钟声在大概一刻钟前敲响，然后他就开始瞎猜了。但他选择的不是一个漂亮的整数。他选择了一个非常精确的数字，因为这给他的声明增添了权威性。所以你可以如此精确的想法在文化上是很诱人的，
but not actually practically possible. Yeah, if you wanna give legitimacy to your testimony, make it really precise. It totally makes sense, but it's really funny. You know, yeah, it really is. And so of course, in this kind of cultural environment where you would rather lie than be caught not knowing the exact time pocket watches
但实际上并不可行。是的，如果你想为你的证词提供合法性，就把它弄得非常精确。这完全说得通，但也真的很搞笑。你知道，是的，确实如此。因此，当然，在这种文化环境中，宁愿撒谎也不愿被人发现不知道确切时间的袖珍手表
are like really coveted items. It was the must have blade, you know, techno blade, but they were pricey. So from about the 1860s, you start to see little businesses setting up with people who have got some sort of a timepiece, giving time information to other people. And so this is when the knocker upper business is really in its heyday, where every urban working class neighbor who had had its own knocker upper, and that person would invest in a good, accurate timepiece, almost like someone invested in
真的是非常令人垂涎的物品。这是必备的刀片，你知道的，科技刀片，但它们很昂贵。因此，大约从 1860 年代开始，你开始看到一些小企业成立，拥有某种计时器的人向其他人提供时间信息。所以正是在这个时候，敲窗人的生意真正达到了全盛时期，每一个拥有自己的敲窗人的城市工薪阶层邻居，那个人会投资一个好的、准确的计时器，几乎就像有人投资
a taxi cab medallion. And then embark on this career and hope to pay that timepiece off and eventually start turning a profit. And was it considered a good career? I mean, I know that having a watch was a high status symbol, but like was being a knocker upper, a high status symbol job? Like, could you make money at it? Well, I asked Ruth about that and she told me you might charge each client maybe like six
一张出租车牌照一样。然后开始这段职业生涯，希望还清计时器的钱，并最终开始盈利。这被认为是一个好职业吗？我的意思是，我知道有一块表是高地位的象征，但作为一名敲窗人是一份高地位的工作吗？也就是说，你能靠它赚钱吗？嗯，我问过鲁思这个问题，她告诉我，你可能会向每个客户收取大概每周六便士的费用，这对我来说当然毫无意义。这算多吗，我猜？那是……嗯，这合理吗？我很想知道这是否是一个……我的意思是，是的，这算合理。我的意思是，如果你有 20 或 30 个客户，那么你勉强可以维持生计，所以这是一个由非常穷的人从事的绝望的职业。特别是老年女性似乎占了很大一部分，有很多年长的女性敲窗人。所以事实证明，像东伦敦的玛丽·安·斯密斯这样的人并不是例外，鲁思说，当我们想到维多利亚时代时，我们喜欢把女性想象成严格呆在家里。
pence per week, which of course meant nothing to me. Is that a lot, I guess? It was that within... Well, is that reasonable? I'm curious if that's like a... I mean, yeah, it's sort of reasonable. I mean, if you had 20 or 30 clients then you could just about scrape some survival so it is a profession of desperation done by people who are really poor. Particularly older women seem to be in a lot of older female knocker uppers. And so it turns out people like Mary Ann Smith of East London or not the exception Ruth says that when we think of the Victorian period, we like to think of the women as being strictly in the home.
但事实是，在下层阶级中，从事重体力劳动、搬运砖块、砸石头、转移黏土的女性数量是巨大的。许多这样的女性在年轻时都是体力劳动者。现在她们达到了这样一个阶段，即她们根本无法再做那种工作了。身体吃不消了。
But the truth is, is that in the lower classes, the number of women earning an income doing heavy manual tasks, hauling bricks, breaking stone, shifting clay was huge. So many of these women will have been physical laborers in the younger years. And now they've reached a point where they simply can't do that. The body won't take it anymore.
而这种敲窗人的工作正是处于那种地位的人会接受的。在某些方面，正如你可以想象的那样，这使她们处于更加脆弱的地位，独自在夜晚漫步在伦敦最粗糙的街区。所以这一定是一份相当危险的工作，我是这么认为的，特别是对于一个年长的女性来说，你必须相当强硬。我的意思是，有些照片显示，其中一些人会带着狗，你知道的，为了个人
And this sort of knocker upper work is the sort of thing that somebody in that position would take. And in some ways, this put them in an even more vulnerable position, as you might imagine, walking the streets of London's roughest neighborhoods alone at night. So it must have been quite a dangerous job, I would have thought, particularly for an older woman, that you would have to be pretty tough. I mean, some of the pictures shows, some of these people who would take a dog with them, you know, personal
安全，你不能怪他们。是的。然而，另一个有趣的从事敲窗人的群体完全不同。那就是警长。绝对的。就像警长的一个小小的兼职工作。就像他们为警长做了一份小小的兼职工作。是的，完全如此。显然，大多数警长都没有手表，就像我们提到的那样，至少没有精确的手表。但那些有的人，如果他们有一块好手表并且值夜班，这是他们可以做来赚点外快的事情。他们可以兼职做敲窗人。令人难以置信的是，你在开膛手杰克的案子中也能看到这一点。第一个受害者，玛丽·尼科尔斯，当那家伙被发现时，他去找了一个警长。他找到了一个警长。
security, and you can't say blame them. Yeah. Another interesting group of people who did knocking up, however, completely different. And that's the police constables. Absolutely. Like a little, a little side gig for the police constables. I was like they did like a little a little side gig for the police constables. Yeah exactly. So apparently most police constables did not have a watch like we mentioned for at least an accurate watch. But those that did, if they had a good watch and a night shift, this was something they could do for a little extra cash. They could just like moonlight as a knocker upper. And incredibly you also see this in the river case. The very first victim, Mary Nichols, when the chat found, he went to find a constable. He found a constable.
他告诉他他发现了这具尸体。而警长正忙着敲窗。他继续去敲窗了。他没有马上过来查看尸体。他有客户。等等。时间就是金钱。你得去完成你的敲窗工作，但尸体可以等。
And he told him he found this body. And the constable was too busy knocking up. He carried on knocking up. He didn't come and see the body immediately. He had clients. White. It's time his money. You got to get your knuckle up job, but the body can wait.
哦，是的，尸体完全可以等。但是，你知道，我仍然愿意相信，如果不是因为他当时在敲窗，我们也许就能知道开膛手杰克是谁了。时间的暴政某种程度上让我们无法得知开膛手杰克是谁。我的意思是，这太有趣了。我的意思是，所有这些人在这些情况下都只是在文化上和经济上受制于这种新型的计时方式，你知道的，无论
Oh, yeah, the body can totally wait. But, you know, I still like to believe that if only he had not been knocking up, we might know who Jack the reference. The tyranny of time has sort of kept us from knowing Jack the Ripper. I mean, it's so interesting. I mean, the way all of these people in these situations are kind of just beholden, you know, culturally and economically to this new form of time keeping, you know, whether
他们是否有测量它的方法。是的。就像你之前说的，机械化的时间还没有进入大多数人的卧室，但不知何故，它在这里伸出了手，几乎字面上敲击着他们的窗户，因为他们必须顺应它。就像时间会来找他们一样，不管他们愿不愿意。是的，当然，这项技术最终也找
they had a way of measuring it or not. Yeah. And like you said earlier, mechanized time wasn't yet in most people's bedrooms, but somehow here it was reaching out and almost literally tapping on their windows because they had to conform to it. Like time was coming for them, whether they liked it or not. Yeah, and of course, this technology eventually came
到了敲窗人头上，一旦我们不再需要他们。我实际上在 1914 年的《卫报》上找到了一篇旧文章，他们在其中采访了一位不知名的敲窗人，描述了这一行业的衰落。他说，敲窗现在已经今非昔比了。曾经我有 60 个客户在我的账上。
for the knocker uppers too, once we no longer had any use for them. And I actually found an old article from the Guardian from 1914, where they interviewed an unknown knocker upper describing the decline of the trade. And he says, one didn't knock him up, isn't what it was. At one time, I had 60 clients on my books.
现在我只有 20 个，而且我已经买下了其他三个人的生意。我估计我将是最后一个敲窗人。当闹钟声音大得足以叫来消防车时，你还能怎么办？半个克朗就能买到一个？我敲了 30 年窗，从来没有打破过一块玻璃，也没有敲错房门，除了那一次。他们让我叫醒他们一个月
Now I've only 20, and I've bought up the businesses of three others. I expect I shall be the last of the aqua uppers. What can you do when alarm clocks loud enough to summon a fire engine? Can be bought for half a crown? I've knocked up for 30 years and never broken a pain or wrapped on the wrong house, except one. And they let me get them up for a month
才告诉我。他说那家人从来没有付过钱。哇，所以这不仅是一份辛苦的工作，随着年复一年，它变得更难了。而且他直到最后都那么有礼貌，那么有礼貌。整个过程看起来极其礼貌，在窗户上有这种轻轻的敲击声。
before they told me. And he says that that family never paid up. Wow, so not only was it a hard job, it got harder as the years went on. And he was just so polite, so polite until the very end. The whole process seems incredibly polite with this kind of light tapping on windows.
看着它被房间里刺耳的闹钟所取代，随风消逝，这有点让人难过。是的，我的意思是，这几乎让我也希望自己能被一个敲窗人叫醒，而不是我的 iPhone。但令人难以置信的是，有些人某种程度上实现了这个愿望，因为这家伙有一件事猜错了，他不是最后一个人。有报道称，英格兰北部博尔顿镇的最后一个敲窗人
It's sort of sad to see it go by the way side for blaring alarms in our rooms. Yeah, I mean, it almost makes me wish I could be woken up by a knocker up on myself instead of my iPhone. But incredibly, some people kind of got this wish because this guy was wrong about one thing he wasn't the last. There are reports that the very, very last of the Nocker
直到 1973 年才退休。1973 年，那是我出生前一年。罗曼，你和敲窗人是同时代的人。这太搞笑了。那么最后一个敲窗人是谁呢？我没能查出来。我不知道他们的性别、他们的客户或他们的方法，但我真的很感动，
uppers in the town of Bolton in Northern England didn't retire until 1973. 1973, something year before I was born. You are a contemporary Roman of knocker uppers. That's hilarious. So who was that last knocker upper? I have not been able to find that out. I don't know their gender or their clients or their method, but I'm just really touched
这个作为变革力量的某种先兆开始的职业，最终却变成了一个传统，并在这一过程中实际上成为了一种计时守旧派。这太美妙了。非常感谢你，乔。谢谢你，99PI 全面远程化了，员工分散在北美各地。所以现在我们的员工分布在四个时区，这可能会让人觉得有点烦人，
that this profession that started out as a kind of harbinger of the forces of change, nevertheless turned into a tradition and in the process actually kind of harbinger of the forces of change. Nevertheless, turned into a tradition, and in the process actually kind of became a time keeping hold out. That is lovely. Well, thank you so much, Joe. Thank you, 9.9 P.I. went all remote and the staff has kind of scattered across North America. And so now we have staffers in four time zones, which can be kind of a pain in the ass,
但我想替代方案会更糟。比如如果我们身处同一个时区，但实际上相距 3,000 英里。是的，完全是这样。这就是我今天要给你们讲的故事。这是一个关于一个时区的故事，一个只有一个时区的地方，以及它是如何与权力和政治以及自由交织在一起的。
but I guess the alternative would be worse. Like if we were one time zone, but actually 3,000 miles away. Yes, exactly. And that's a story that I have for you right now. It's a story about one time zone, a place with only one time zone, and how it's become intertwined with power and politics
哇。好吧。嗯，这很戏剧性。说来听听。好的。就像你提到的，像美国、加拿大或俄罗斯这样非常宽广的国家。我们有多个时区来划分一天，因为否则一天的日照量
and freedom. Wow. Okay. Well, this is dramatic. Let's hear it. Yeah. Like so, as you mentioned, very wide countries like the US or Canada or Russia. We have these multiple time zones to break up the day because otherwise the amount of daylight
会根据你向东或向西有多远而分布不均。但有一个领土非常宽广的国家，在整个领土上只使用一个官方时区，那就是中国。嗯，整个国家只有一个时区。是的。根据吉尼斯世界纪录大全，它实际上是世界上拥有单一时区面积最大的国家。我的意思是，总的来说它是世界上最大的国家之一。所以，我想是的。
in a day would be unevenly distributed depending on how far east or how far west you are. But there is a country with a very wide land mass that only uses one official time zone across the entire territory and that's China. Huh, one time zone across the entire country. Yeah. And according to the Guinness book of world records, it's actually the largest country in the world with only one time zone. I mean, it's one of the largest countries in the world in general. So, I guess so.
但是中国有多宽呢？我们这里讨论的是什么尺度？它大致和美国或加拿大一样宽。正如中国的许多天文学家多次指出的那样，按照常理它应该包含五个时区，通常每 15 度一个。这位是加德纳·博文顿。他是印第安纳大学中亚研究系和国际研究系的副教授。
But how wide is China? Like, what are we working with here? It's roughly as wide as the United States or Canada. And as astronomers in China have pointed out many times, it really byel rides ought to have five time zones with generally go every 15 degrees. So this is Gardner Bovington. He's an associate professor in the departments of Central Eurasian Studies and International Studies
哇，加德纳·博文顿。是的。下次我用化名登记入住酒店时，我就用加德纳·博文的名字。这名字太好了。我也是这么说的。有没有人跟你说过，你的名字非常适合做播客？
at Indiana University. Wow, Gardner Bovington. Yeah. Next time I check into OOTEL under a pseudonym, I'm going in as Gardener Boving. That is such a good name. That's exactly what I said. Has anybody ever told you that you have the perfect name for a podcast?
以前有人提到过。太棒了。所以如果加德纳说中国实际上应该包含五个不同的时区，为什么它只运行一个时区？而且一直都是这样吗？不，不是这样的。事实上，跨国计时在二战结束前一直相当混乱。
It has been mentioned before. So awesome. So if Gardener is saying that China should actually encompass five different time zones, why does it operate with only one? And has it always been like this? No, it hasn't. And actually, timekeeping in cross-country was sort of all over the place until the end of World War II.
在很短的一段时间里，他们实际上在全国范围内遵守了五个时区。但在 1949 年中华人民共和国成立后，这一切都被抛弃了。因此，共产党刚刚赢得了这场漫长的内战，领导层认为在中国的每个时钟上保持一个国家时间是将一个分裂的国家联合起来的一种非常字面的方式。一个国家在试图触及全国各地的人民时面临许多挑战，也就是我们所说的国家的影响力。
And for a brief period of time, they actually did observe five time zones across the country. But that was all thrown out in 1949 after the establishment of the People's Republic of China. So the Communist Party had just won this long civil war, and leadership thought that having one national time on every clock across China was this very literal way to unite a fractured country. A state has many challenges in trying to touch people in all the parts of the country, what we call the reach of the state.
这是一个快速、非常有效的方法，就是说只有一个时间，这是我们为整个国家使用的时间。那个时间被称为北京时间。这意味着当北京时间是上午 9 点时，2700 英里之外的喀什也是上午 9 点。是的，让我震撼的一点是，如果你看一张地图，北京，那是国家首都，全国时间以此为基础。它就像一直延伸到这些中国东北部地区。所以这把西方所有的人搞得——如果它是居中的，至少你还有点东西可以依靠，
This was a quick, very efficient way to do it, to say there's one time, and it's the time we're using for the entire country. That time is called Beijing time. Which means that when it's 9 a.m. in Beijing, it's 9 a.m. 2700 miles away in Kashgar. Yes, one thing I'm struck by is that if you look at a map, Beijing, that's the nation's capital where the national time is based. It's like all the way up in these were northeastern part of China. And so like that leaves everyone to the west like really like if it was centered, at least you would have something to work with.
你知道我的意思吗？但它确实位于一个极端的地理位置。那么远西部的人们是如何应对一个根本不符合他们的太阳时的时钟的呢？是的，加德纳实际上是新疆的研究学者，新疆是中国西北部的一个自治领土。它非常靠西，大约有 1200 万维吾尔人居住在那里，他们是新疆本地的少数民族。他们说维吾尔语，信仰伊斯兰教，在文化上与占全国人口约 92% 的汉族多数群体有很大不同。
You know what I mean? But it's really in one extreme location. So how does people in the far west deal with the clock that doesn't match their solar day, like really at all? Yeah, so gardeners actually is a scholar of Xinjiang, which is an autonomous territory in the north west of China. It's really far west, and it's home to about 12 million Uighurs who are an ethnic minority native to Xinjiang. They speak Uighur and are Muslim, and they are very different culturally from the Han majority, which make up about 92% of the country.
几十年来，中国政府一直担心该地区的分裂主义，这导致了国家资助的对维吾尔人生活的相当严重的镇压，以及正在进行的种族灭绝。我稍后会详细讲这个。好的，好的。我收回。但我想要倒回 1990 年代，当时加德纳第一次开始前往新疆。我第一次去新疆是在 1994 年。他在该地区进行实地研究，并意识到新疆其实存在两个独立的时区。一个是北京时间，这是官方的
And for decades, the Chinese government has worried about separatism in the region, and it's led to pretty severe state-sponsored suppression of weer life, and to an ongoing genocide. I'll get more into this later. Okay, okay. I'll put up an envelope. But I wanted to kind of rewind back to the 1990s when Gardiner first began traveling to Xinjiang. My first trip to Xinjiang was in 1994. He was doing field research in the region and he realized that there were actually two separate time zones that existed in Xinjiang. There was Beijing time, which was the official
国家时间，当地的汉族人使用的是这个时间。但随后维吾尔族人口使用了一种完全不同的时间，称为新疆时间或地方时间。直到我开始懂维吾尔语时，我才听到人们在维吾尔语中使用这个表达新疆时间的词。然后我开始想，等一下，他们为什么这么说？接着我开始注意到他们使用的时间，他们用来表示时间的数字与
national time, and this was used by the Han Chinese in the area. But then there was this totally different time that was used by the Uyghur population called Xinjiang time or local time. It was only when I started to understand Weger that I heard people using this expression for Xinjiang time in Weger. And then I started thinking, wait a minute, why are they saying that? Then I started noticing that the time that they used, the numbers they used for time were two hours off
北京时间相差两个小时。因此，北京时间过去是，现在仍然是新疆的官方时区。所以像火车站和政府机关这样的地方，它们都按北京的钟表运行。如果你问一个汉族人现在几点，他们会用北京时间告诉你。但加德纳注意到，如果问一个维吾尔族人现在几点，他们最有可能回答的是“地方时间”，
that of Beijing time. So Beijing time was and still is the official time zone in Xinjiang. So things like train stations and government offices They all run on Beijing's clock And if you were to ask a Han person what time it was they would tell you in Beijing time But Gardner noticed that if a weaker person were asked what time it was they would most likely respond with the quote local time Which was two hours behind Beijing and this was because it more closely followed
比北京时间慢两个小时。这是因为这更贴近新疆的太阳运行规律。嗯，这很复杂，至少从加德纳在 90 年代观察到的情况来看是这样。这在日常生活中是如何运作的呢？是的，所以举个例子，比如我们所说的中午。也就是说，基本上是太阳一天中最高的时候。好的。如果你问一个维吾尔族人现在几点，他们可能会说是中午 12 点。
the solar pattern of Xinjiang. Well, that is complicated, at least from what Gornner observed back in the 90s. How did that work in everyday life? Yeah, so take, for example, what we call noon. So like, basically, when the sun is at a tia's point in the day. OK. If you were to ask someone who was weaker what time it was, they might say it was 12 p.m.
但如果你问一个汉族人，他们可能会告诉你其实是下午 2 点。所以对于新疆的汉族人来说，生活比地方时间提前了两个小时开始。他们是在黑暗中醒去上班，只是为了应付这种不便，仅仅为了与北京保持一致，按照北京时间工作吗？我，是的，我也想过这一点，但并没有。既然我一开始就提到北京希望借此将其权力延伸到整个
But if you were to ask someone who was Han, they would probably tell you it was actually 2 p.m. So for Han Chinese people in Xinjiang, life has just lived two hours earlier than local time. Are they waking up and going to work in the dark and just dealing with the inconvenience just to keep in step with Beijing to work Beijing hours. I, yeah, I wondered that too, but no. Since I started out by suggesting Beijing wanted to sort of extend its authority over the whole
国家并表明它正在这样做，那么人们起床，对吧，为了在八点或九点北京时间准备好在他们的工作单位工作等等，这可能是有道理的。在某个时期可能确实如此，但我的印象是在 1990 年代和 2000 年代并非如此，即使是使用北京时间的汉族人也将时间推迟了两个小时。现在，我对这一点很好奇，我问了一些人，所以单一时区的便利性在某种程度上被一个事实所打破：如果一个北京官员在上午 9 点（北京时间）打电话，乌鲁木齐工作单位的人根本不会在办公室里，对吧？那个人说，嗯，是的，但这是心照不宣的。所以汉族人实际上是按照新疆的太阳时间生活的，尽管他们使用北京的
country and show that it was doing so, it might make sense for people to get up, right, for people to get up, right, to be ready at their work unit at eight or nine Beijing time, and so on. And that might have been so at one time, but my impression was in the 1990s and 2000s that that wasn't so, that even Hans who used Beijing time shifted two hours. Now, I was curious about this, and I asked some people, so the convenience of one time zone is kind of defied by the fact that if a Beijing official calls at 9 o'clock in the morning, Beijing time, the person in the work unit in Urim Ji is not going to be in the office, right? The person said, well, yeah, but that's understood. So Han people actually lived by Shin Jong-jiang solar time, even though they used Beijing's
时钟来交流时间。就像，好吧。所以，你知道，这两个时区互相碰撞的频率有多高？因为，我的意思是，这听起来太混乱了。是的，我的意思是，某种程度上是这样的。所以，如果你是一个外国人，你要跟当地人见面，你可能应该说明他们用的是哪个时间。我读过一个汉族人的叙事，他碰巧有很多维吾尔族朋友。他感到很恼火，因为他总是去任何事情都提前两个小时。但加德纳说，在大多数情况下，
clocks to communicate the time. Like, okay. So, you know, how much did these two time zones bump into each other? Because, I mean, it just sounds so confusing. Yeah, I mean, kind of. So, if you're a foreigner and you're meeting up with a local, you should probably specify which time they're using. I was reading this account from a Han Chinese person who happened to be friends with a lot of Uighurs. And he was annoyed because he would always show up like two hours early for everything. But Garner said that in most cases,
并没有那么令人困惑，因为维吾尔人基本上通过他们说的话的语言或者他们正在交谈的对象就知道该参考哪个时钟。就像如果他们在和维吾尔族的家人或朋友说话，也许他们会说，嘿，我早上 8 点出门上班。但如果他们是在用普通话和汉族人说话，他们会自动知道说，嘿，我上午 10 点出门上班。听起来就像典型的语码转换。
it wasn't all that confusing because Uighurs basically knew which clock to refer to by the language that they were speaking or who they were speaking to. Like if they were talking to a Uighur family member or a friend, maybe they would say, hey, I'm leaving for work at 8 AM. But if they were speaking Mandarin to a Han person, they automatically knew to say, hey, I'm leaving for work at 10 a.m. I mean, that sounds just like classic code switching.
但你知道，维吾尔族人必须根据他们交谈对象的文化来调整他们的语言。而且他们会知道要这么做。责任在于他们自己去这样做。是的，完全如此。我实际上在 1994 年并不知道“语码转换”这个词。今天，我认为你说得很对。完全正确。所以存在语言代码，对吧？
But you know, someone who is weaker would have to adjust their language depending on the culture of the person they were talking to. And they would know to do it. And they would be the onus would be on them to do it. Yeah, exactly. I didn't actually know the word code switching in 1994. Today, I think you're spot on. It's exactly right. So there are linguistic codes, right?
当一个讲西班牙语和英语的双语者说话时，她会使用英语版的名称来方便英语使用者，并切换到西班牙语版的名称，以免被其他西班牙语使用者嘲笑。这里我们谈论的是时间代码，切换时间代码。让我觉得有趣的是，一天中的时间实际上取决于你询问的对象的民族。是的，是的。
When a bilingual Spanish English speaker speaks, she will use the Anglo version of names to convenience English speakers, and switch to the Spanish version of names in order not to be mocked by fellow Spanish speakers. And here we're talking about time codes, switching time codes. It is interesting to me that the time of day actually depended on the ethnicity of who you were asking. Yeah, yeah.
加德纳说他认为这实际上是一个政治声明。你知道，就像即使在 1990 年代对维吾尔人来说，公开的异议也可能被解释为分裂主义的威胁，这会给他们招惹中国政府的很大麻烦。但通过选择将手表对准地方时间而不是北京时间，这感觉像是一种安静而私人的抗议或声援形式。人们可能不敢公开表现出敌意、公开抵抗、公开示威等等，所以相反，他们会寻找微小的、可能是隐蔽的或半隐蔽的方式来表达他们的反抗，
And Gardner says that he thought that this was actually a political statement. You know, like even in the 1990s for Uyghurs, open dissent could be interpreted as a threat of separatism, which could get you in a lot of trouble with the Chinese government. But by choosing to set your watch to local time instead of Beijing time, it felt like this quiet and private form of protest or solidarity. People might not dare to be openly hostile, openly resistant, openly demonstrating so forth. And so instead they'll find little ways possibly hidden or half hidden to express their defiance
并向彼此展示他们正在反抗政府。因此，我们可以说，将自己的日常时间表保持在新疆时间上，并在被追问时称其为新疆时间并拒绝北京时间，都是日常抵抗的模式。这实在是太迷人了。鉴于现在从新疆传出的新闻的强度，现在使用新疆时间的安全性如何？
and to show each other that they are defying the government. And so we could say that keeping one's daily schedule on Xinjiang time and when pressed calling it Xinjiang time and rejecting Beijing time are all modes of everyday resistance. That is just so fascinating. And it's given the intensity of the news coming out of Xinjiang now, like, how safe is it to use Xinjiang time presently?
我的意思是，有多隐秘，你能……？是的。是的。正如你所注意到的，加德纳对地方时间与北京时间对比的观察主要发生在 1990 年代和 2000 年代初。基本上，加德纳是一群称自己为“新疆十三人”的学者之一，
Like, how secret and can you mean? Yeah. Yeah. So as you noticed, Gardiner's observations of local time versus Beijing time mainly took place in the 1990s and early 2000s. Basically, Gardiner is part of a group that calls himself the Xinjiang 13,
比如，到底有多机密，你指的是什么？对，对。正如你所注意到的，加德纳对地方时间与北京时间对比的观察主要发生在20世纪90年代和21世纪初。基本上，加德纳是一个自称为“新疆13人”的群体的一员，
their group of scholars who have essentially been pretty much barred from entering China because of a scholarly work that they wrote about Xinjiang. So he hasn't actually been able to return to China since 2005. So that's why most of this comes from like the early 90s or the mid 90s. But over the past few years, the human rights crisis has escalated severely. It's at the point where the US has determined that what's happening to the U.S. and Shin Jong is genocide.
他们的学者群体基本上已经被禁止进入中国，因为他们写过一本文关于新疆的学术著作。所以他自2005年以来实际上就无法返回中国。这就是为什么这些情况大多来自90年代初或90年代中期。但在过去的几年里，人权危机急剧升级。情况已经到了美国认定发生在美国和新疆的事情是种族灭绝的地步。
Mass and term end of up to two million members of the mostly Muslim-ethnic minority group, the U.S. Psychological Torture. U.S. and other countries have labeled China's treatment of Wiggers as genocide. That China may be expanding. It's so-called reeducation camps. And among many other human rights violations, a large population of Wiggers and other Muslim
多达200万主要为穆斯林少数民族的成员遭到大规模无限期关押，美国称其为心理折磨。美国和其他国家已将中国对维吾尔人的待遇定性为种族灭绝。中国可能正在扩大其所谓的再教育营。在众多其他人权侵犯行为中，大量维吾尔族和其他穆斯林
minorities have been detained in what have officially been called, you know, vocational education training centers, but are effectively reeducation camps. I mean, clearly they're camps, which is a distinction between other schools or training centers or prisons as well in some ways, but it's very clear from people that have been in them that have worked in them, they are actually camps that they're a prison space,
少数民族被关押在官方被称为职业教育培训中心的地方，但实际上就是再教育营。我的意思是，显然它们就是营地，这在某种程度上与其它学校、培训中心或监狱有所区别，但从那些进去过、在那里工作过的人那里非常清楚，它们实际上就是营地，是监狱空间，
a carceral space, really a medium security prison. So this is Darren Biler. He's an anthropologist at Simon Frazier University. And he studies how ethnic minorities in Northwest China are surveilled and policed. He's done a lot of field work in Xinjiang and was last there in 2018. And he says that because of the pervasiveness
一个具有惩罚性质的空间，实际上是一个中等安全级别的监狱。这就是达伦·拜勒（Darren Biler）。他是西蒙弗雷泽大学的一名人类学家。他研究中国西北部的少数民族是如何被监控和管制的。他在新疆做过很多田野调查，最后一次去是在2018年。他说，由于
of surveillance technology paired with smartphone use, using local time could actually be potentially dangerous. I'm sure most people now have their phones set to Beijing time. And most people expect to have their phone checked to have it scanned, or in some cases, they're forced to install nanny apps on their phone, which will upload the data that's being
监控技术与智能手机的使用无处不在，使用当地时间实际上可能会带来潜在危险。我确信现在大多数人的手机都设置为北京时间。大多数人都预计他们的手机会被检查、扫描，或者在某些情况下，他们被迫在手机上安装间谍软件，这些软件会上传正在
collected on their phone. So most people are aware that everything on their phone is basically state property at this point. And it's not that it's necessarily against the law to use local time, but Darren says that a weaker person could be, you know, putting themselves in a vulnerable position if they had their phones set to anything other than Beijing time. So in the government documents or in documents that are, you know, in circulation in the Chinese internet from Xinjiang, they talk really directly about this issue. They say that you should look really carefully
手机上收集的数据。因此，大多数人都意识到，在这一点上，手机上的所有东西基本上都是国家财产。这并不是说使用当地时间一定违法，但达伦说，如果维吾尔人把手机设置为北京时间以外的任何时间，他们可能会把自己置于脆弱的境地。因此，在政府文件或在中国互联网上流传的新疆文件中，他们非常直接地谈到了这个问题。他们说，你应该仔细观察
at people that are using local time. They don't say outright that it's illegal necessarily in most cases, but it is certainly something that they're looking at as a sign of suspicion. And there's a laundry list of things that can be interpreted as a quote, sign of separatism, like wearing a head scarf, having a beard, having what's installed on your phone, or simply speaking to someone who lives abroad. These are all things that have gotten people in trouble with the government. And Darren even said that he noticed people having to self-censor themselves in all these
使用当地时间的人。在大多数情况下，他们并没有直截了当说这一定是非法的，但它绝对是他们视为可疑迹象的事情。有一长串可以被解释为所谓分离主义迹象的事情，比如戴头巾、留胡子、手机上安装了什么，或者仅仅是与居住在海外的人说话。这些都是让人们与政府陷入麻烦的事情。达伦甚至说，他注意到人们不得不以各种
private ways, like having to change the way that they greet each other over the phone so that they drop Islamic identifiers. So time is just one example of how these intimate parts of weaker culture are being suppressed. It's a sign of them potentially being separatists, of being more loyal to their own ethnicity, their own geographic location than the nation. And so there's definitely pressure on people to use Beijing time. I mean, when you think about the history of the implementation of one time zone, you see it sort of presaging all this other form of suppression that has these differences that
私密的方式进行自我审查，比如不得不改变在电话里互相打招呼的方式，从而去除伊斯兰标识。所以时间只是维吾尔文化中这些亲密部分如何被压制的一个例子。这是他们可能成为分离主义者、对自己的民族、自己的地理位置比对国家更忠诚的迹象。因此，人们肯定面临使用北京时间的压力。我的意思是，当你思考单一时区实施的历史时，你会看到它似乎预示着所有其他形式的压制，这些压制表现为那些
are perfectly capable of existing inside of one country. You know, like time zones can exist inside one country, and it's just kind of stunning that they once had five time zones and created one. You know, and what that says about everything else. Yeah, and Gardner Bovington from earlier in the piece said that, you know, even from the beginning, it was very clear who wasn't going to fit into a system built on Beijing time. You design a system of timekeeping that's manifestly at odds with the local experience of the suns transit through the sky.
完全有能力存在于一个国家内部的差异。你知道，就像时区可以存在于一个国家内部一样，他们曾经有过五个时区却创造了一个，这真是令人震惊。你知道，这说明了其他一切。是的，前面片段中的加德纳·博文顿说，你知道，从一开始，就很清楚谁将不适合建立在北京时间基础上的系统。你设计了一种时间保持系统，这与太阳穿过天空的本地经验明显不一致。
And so reminds people constantly, you are at the periphery. You're not in the center. Gardener said something kind of interesting, which was like, the reason why it's set to Beijing time is because this is a capital. This is where the orders emanate. This is where you should be looking for leadership. But that really shows how little thought that they put into the people, you know, 3000 miles away in the West,
因此，它不断提醒人们，你们在边缘。你们不在中心。加德纳说了一件挺有趣的事，那就是，之所以设置为北京时间，是因为这里是首都。这是命令发出的地方。这是你应该寻找领导力的地方。但这真的表明他们对远在三千英里外的西方人民投入了多么少的心思，
like how little consideration that it took to consider what their days might look like. And how little consideration they had for the sun, like it is telling to me that there's this denial of reality that goes along with this denial of human rights. Well, he's not surprising to me that those two things go together. Yeah.
比如他们花了多么少的考虑去思考他们的日子可能会是什么样子。他们对太阳的考虑是多么少，对我来说很有说明意义的是，这种对人权的否定伴随着对现实的否定。好吧，这两件事结合在一起对我来说并不令人惊讶。是的。
Well, I got really intense there at the end. I thought we were just gonna talk about time zones. Well, that was incredibly fascinating. Thank you so much. Thank you. When we come back, Chris Baroube on the surprisingly controversial issue of springing forward and falling back after this.
好吧，最后变得非常紧张。我以为我们只是要讨论时区。好吧，这真是太迷人了。非常感谢。谢谢。当我们回来时，克里斯·巴鲁布（Chris Baroube）将讨论关于在春天向前拨和在秋天向后拨这个令人惊讶的具争议性的问题，之后见。
So I'm here with Chris Baroube and Chris, you want to talk about one of the great time-related debates. I do. I want to talk to you today about daylight saving time. And so I always say daylight saving time. Is it not daylight saving time? Absolutely not. That is not what I'm going to talk about.
所以我在这里和克里斯·巴鲁布在一起，克里斯，你想讨论一个伟大的与时间相关的辩论。我是的。我今天想和你讨论夏令时（Daylight saving time）。所以我总是说夏令时。这不是夏令时吗？绝对不是。那不是我要讨论的。
No, in all the legislation that has made DST daylight saving time happen, they dropped the S. But that's not the controversy around it. There's other controversies related to daylight saving time. It's something that, you know, people around the world kind of take for granted in large parts of North America and Europe and South America. And you know how daylight saving time works. It's in the summer, we spring forward one hour. So that's actually the daylight being saved
不，在所有促成夏令时（DST）实现的立法中，他们去掉了S。但这不是围绕它的争议。还有其他与夏令时相关的争议。这是人们在北美、欧洲和南美的很大一部分地区习以为常的事情。你知道夏令时是如何运作的。在夏天，我们向前拨一个小时。所以实际上被节省的日光
is the extra daylight in the evening when the sun sets later. And then around October, it falls back. So then you lose an hour and you have an earlier sunset. And it's something that I've been used to because I've had it my whole life. It's just a thing that happens twice a year. But it's actually really controversial.
是傍晚时太阳落山更晚时的额外日光。然后在10月左右，它向后拨。所以你就失去了一个小时，日落时间变早了。这是我习惯的事情，因为我一辈子都有它。这只是每年发生两次的事情。但它实际上非常有争议。
And there are people who are trying to change the future of daylight saving time right now. And that's what I want to talk about. But before we get to that, Roman, do you know where daylight saving time comes from? I was always told that it was because of farmers that they needed more daylight to do farming. That is not at all the case.
有些人现在正试图改变夏令时的未来。这就是我想讨论的。但在我们讨论那个之前，罗曼，你知道夏令时从哪里来吗？我一直被告知这是因为农民需要更多的日光来从事农业。根本不是这回事。
Much like daylight savings time, it is a myth that it's about farmers. And I know that because I called this guy. This is Dr. David Prarow. I'm the author of the book, Seize the Daylight, the curious and contentious story of daylight saving time. He actually is the world expert on the subject of DST. I don't like to say that, but yes, some people have said that. When people find out that you are a daylight saving expert, do they get mad at you?
就像夏令时一样，关于它是为了农民的说法是一个神话。我知道这一点是因为我给这个人打了电话。这是大卫·普拉罗（David Prarow）博士。我是《抓住日光：夏令时好奇且充满争议的故事》一书的作者。他实际上是夏令时领域的全球专家。我不太喜欢这么说，但是的，有些人这么说。当人们发现你是夏令时专家时，他们会生你的气吗？
Are they like, because I feel like it is a charged thing, like people have strong opinions about it. Well, what happens is when they lose the day they lose the hour of sleep, everybody gets bad at me. The day they sleep an extra hour, nobody comes and thanks me. So when I was talking to Dr. Prairie, I brought up the farmer thing that everyone seems to think about daylight saving. And what he told me is it's a total myth. Farmers, many people think daylight saving say that was put into help the farmers,
他们会吗？因为我觉得这是一个敏感的话题，人们对此有强烈的看法。嗯，发生的事情是，当他们失去了一小时的睡眠时，每个人都对我很生气。他们多睡一个小时的那天，没有人来感谢我。所以当我与普拉罗博士交谈时，我提出了每个人似乎都想到的关于夏令时的农民理论。而他告诉我的完全是一个神话。农民，许多人认为夏令时是为了帮助农民，
and they see exact 100% opposite. They have to follow the sun, independent of what the clock says. So you might say so, why? Well, they just threw it in, you know, and everybody else changed the clock. But the problem is that farmers have to interact with the rest of the world.
而他们看到的情况完全是100%相反的。他们必须遵循太阳，独立于时钟怎么说。所以你可能会说，为什么？好吧，他们只是把它加进去了，你知道，其他所有人都改变了时钟。但问题是农民必须与世界其余部分互动。
They have to bring products to market. So farmers have to interact with the rest of the world. They have to bring products to market. So farmers have to get up with the sun and the businesses they're working with are using the clock. So it's inconvenient when twice a year the clock-based businesses are shifting their time around. So the headline here is, farmers are not responsible for daylight saving time. The credit slash blame belongs to a British house builder named William Willett. And each morning he'd wake up at sunrise, go out for a horseback ride around his area. And while he was on one of these morning horseback rides, he would realize that everybody else is asleep
他们必须将产品推向市场。所以农民必须与世界其余部分互动。他们必须将产品推向市场。所以农民必须随着太阳起床，而他们合作的企业却在使用时钟。因此，当每年两次基于时钟的企业改变时间时，这是很不方便的。所以这里的头条是，农民不应该对夏令时负责。荣誉/责备应该归功于一个名叫威廉·威利特（William Willett）的英国房屋建筑商。每天早晨他都在日出时醒来，在他的地区周围骑马。当他在这些早晨骑马的时候，他会意识到其他人都在睡觉
and they're not making good use of the beautiful spring and summer mornings. So he wrote this pamphlet called a waste of daylight. He wrote this pamphlet promoting the idea of pushing back the clocks one hour in the summer and it was really influential and the British parliament actually took up his idea. That's how influential his pamphlet became. Well and did they approve it based off his pamphlet? They did not.
他们没有好好利用美丽的春夏早晨。所以他写了一本名为《浪费日光》的小册子。他写了一本小册子，宣传在夏天将时钟拨后一小时的想法，这非常具有影响力，英国议会实际上采用了他的想法。他的小册子变得如此有影响力。嗯，他们根据他的小册子批准了它吗？他们没有。
So some politicians argued this was a completely pointless thing. They were like, hey, if you want more daylight, when did you just wake up earlier? Like, go further? Yeah, it seemed intuitive to them. So they rejected it. But, well, we're not the type to be disweighted. So the next year, he came back again with the same proposal
所以一些政治家认为这是一件完全毫无意义的事情。他们就像，嘿，如果你想要更多的日光，你为什么不早点醒来？比如，走得更远？是的，这对他们来说似乎是直观的。所以他们拒绝了。但是，嗯，我们不是那种容易气馁的人。所以第二年，他又带着同样的提议回来了
and the same proposal the next year. And the next year as it kept being considered, but rejected. And this became a perennial piece of legislation. So actually like Winston Churchill became a champion of this. He was the headline speaker at a big rally for daylight saving, but it was rejected in 1911. It was rejected in saving, but it was rejected in 1911. It was rejected in 1912. It was rejected in 1913.
第二年也是同样的提议。接下来的几年里，这个提议不断被考虑但被拒绝。这成了一项长期的立法。所以实际上温斯顿·丘吉尔（Winston Churchill）成了这方面的拥护者。他是支持夏令时的大型集会上的主要发言人，但在1911年被拒绝了。在1911年被拒绝了。在1912年被拒绝了。在1913年被拒绝了。
It was rejected in 1914. And then... In 1950, unfortunately, Willett passed away. Never to ever see his idea-computer fruition. If Willett had lived one more year, he would have seen his idea implemented. Because in 1916, World War I was in full swing, and across all of the country's fighting in the war, there was an energy crisis because a lot of coal miners had joined the military. So they wanted to save energy because there wasn't enough coal miners to actually provide
在1914年被拒绝了。然后……在1950年，不幸的是，威利特去世了。永远没有看到他的想法变为现实。如果威利特多活一年，他就会看到他的想法得以实施。因为在1916年，第一次世界大战正如火如荼地进行，在所有参战国中，由于许多煤矿工人参军，出现了一场能源危机。所以他们想要节约能源，因为没有足够的煤矿工人来实际提供
the energy that they needed to run the country? Exactly. And Germany, the first country to realize, like, hey, one great way to save energy is to do this daylight saving thing that Britain has been considering for all these years. So Germany brings it in, and then immediately Britain becomes really jealous. Within a month, after having rejected it for seven or eight years, within a month of the Germans putting it in the British put it, and eventually the countries put it in on both sides of the war. And that's how we got daylight saving is because of World War One.
运行国家所需的能源？完全正确。而德国是第一个意识到，嘿，节约能源的一个好方法就是实行英国多年来一直在考虑的这个夏令时。所以德国引入了它，然后英国立刻变得非常嫉妒。在拒绝了七八年后，在一个月内，在德国人引入后，英国人也引入了，最终战争双方的国家都引入了。这就是我们通过第一次世界大战获得夏令时的过程。
That's amazing. And also keeping up with the Joneses during World War One, which is an amazing part of that story. Yeah, it might be more accurate to say we got it because of World War One and jealousy. Those are the causes of it. And actually at first it was, it was really complicated. It was a big problem because people kept breaking their clocks, because the clocks were not built in a way that you could manually move the
这太惊人了。还有在第一次世界大战期间与邻居攀比（keeping up with the Joneses），这是这个故事中令人惊叹的一部分。是的，更准确的说法可能是我们因为第一次世界大战和嫉妒而得到了它。这些是它的起因。实际上起初它是，它真的很复杂。这是一个大问题，因为人们不断弄坏他们的时钟，因为时钟的制造方式不是你可以手动移动
hour hands back and forth. But fast forward, a hundred years. And throughout the last century, most of Europe adopted daylight saving time. It spreads to North America. Countries around the world have tried using it on and off. And what we see now is about 70 countries worldwide have daylight saving time. And even though it's common,
时针来回拨动的。但快进一百年。在上个世纪，欧洲大部分地区采用了夏令时。它蔓延到北美。世界各国的尝试断断续续地使用它。我们现在看到的是全球大约有70个国家拥有夏令时。尽管它很常见，
it's still pretty controversial. Like I grew up in Canada, I really like daylight saving time in the summer because you get that extra sunlight in the evening. But I'll say during Canadian winters when daylight saving time in the summer because you get that extra sunlight in the evening, but I'll say during Canadian winters, when daylight saving time goes away and we go back to standard time, it can be brutal. Like, there are parts of Canada where you can just get these really early sunsets. Well, that part of daylight saving is not that I have a problem with daylight saving in terms of like, I think it should be there all the time. You mean, like, I don't understand why it needs to fall back.
这仍然相当具有争议。比如我在加拿大长大，我真的很喜欢夏天的夏令时，因为傍晚能多出一些阳光。但我得说，在加拿大漫长的冬天里，当夏令时结束、我们调回标准时间时，那感觉简直太残酷了。比如，在加拿大的某些地方，日落会变得非常早。好吧，夏令时的那部分并不是我对夏令时有意见，我是指从某种角度来说，我认为它应该一直存在。你的意思是，我不明白为什么非得把时钟往回拨。
I think it's the thing. So my sense of the controversy is the period of time that is not daylight saving time, not the part that is. Does that make sense? Yeah, and you're not alone in that position at all, because about 10 years ago, there was a political movement in the United Kingdom where this whole idea comes from to take daylight saving
我认为这就是关键所在。所以我的感觉是，争议所在的时间段其实是不属于夏令时的时间段，而不是属于夏令时的时间段。这说得通吗？是的，而且持这种观点的人绝不在少数，因为大约10周年以前，英国（这个概念正发源于此）曾发起过一场政治运动，旨在改变夏令时。
time and push it even further. Oh, that's exciting. Well, here's a question. Could this weekend be the last time we put the clocks back, assuming you remember to of course? Well, there are growing calls this lunchtime for exactly that, saying the current system is outdated. You go to work as dark, you come home as dark, hated.
并将其推向更远的未来。哦，太令人兴奋了。好吧，这里有个问题：假设你还记得要拨表的话，这个周末会不会是我们最后一次把时钟往回拨？好吧，在这个午餐时间，越来越多的人呼吁正是如此，他们认为现有的系统已经过时了。天黑去上班，天黑回家，这令人讨厌。
Perhaps we should do with an extra hour light, get a lot more done when it's like children can play out longer. And it became this really popular campaign. It actually had a catchy name. The name of the campaign was lighter later. Later later. Joining me now, I'd lighter, lighter, lighter, lighter, lighter campaign. Money lighter, lighter, lighter, this is Daniel campaign. Good morning. Lighter, lighter campaign. This is Daniel.
也许我们应该增加一个小时的光照，当天亮时能做成更多的事，孩子们也能在外面玩得久一点。于是这就成了一场非常受欢迎的运动。它甚至还有一个十分洗脑的名字。这场运动的名字叫“让天黑得更晚一些”。晚一点，再晚一点。现在加入我的是……“让天黑得更晚一些”运动。资金……“让天黑得更晚一些”，这是丹尼尔的运动。早上好。“让天黑得更晚一些”运动。我是丹尼尔。
Yeah, memorable name really hard to say. And actually, the lighter, lighter campaign wasn't just about moving the clocks up one hour in the winter. That campaign actually proposed that we double daylight saving time in the summer. You're going to have to explain what that means, because I have a very tenuous grasp on daylight saving as it is.
是的，名字挺好记，但真难念。事实上，“让天黑得更晚一些”运动不仅仅是在冬天把时钟往前提一个小时。那场运动实际上提议我们在夏天将夏令时加倍。你得解释一下这是什么意思，因为我对夏令时的理解本来就非常模糊。
So it's complicated, but please bear with me. So under later later, you'd have an extra hour of daylight in the winter, basically you wouldn't do the fallback. Fallback, okay. And then just for a treat, just for fun, let's actually give ourselves one other hour of daylight in the summer.
所以这很复杂，但请听我慢慢道来。因此，在“让天黑得更晚一些”方案下，冬天你会多出一个小时的日光，基本上就是不用把时钟往回拨了。往回拨，好吧。然后，作为一种福利，就当是好玩吧，我们在夏天其实可以再给自己增加一个小时的日光。
So basically the clocks will move forward one hour all year round. In the winter and great Britain, you'd be on summer time and in the summer you'd be on something called double summer time. So it shifts everything. That's exactly right. And when this campaign was rolling out, they were listing all these benefits and like, just listen to the list of benefits of double daylight saving time. It sounds really good.
所以基本上全年的时钟都要向前拨一个小时。在冬天的大不列颠，你将处于夏令时，而在夏天，你将处于一种叫做“双倍夏令时”的状态。所以它把一切都错开了。完全正确。而当这场运动推出时，他们列出了所有这些好处，听听双倍夏令时带来的好处列表吧。听起来真的很棒。
It's claimed the overall health of the nation would improve as people could enjoy daylight for longer. Children they'd benefit as many of them aren't allowed to leave their homes after dark. They'd be able to play outside for longer. It's estimated up to a hundred road deaths could be prevented annually across Britain due to better visibility And around 450,000 tons of CO2 would be saved by people switching their lights on later It's great for the environment. It's great for safety. It's great for health like what is not to love about this idea I mean, it sounds fantastic. It does it does seem like as you begin to creep up even further It'd be really dark in the morning, right?
据称，由于人们可以享受更长时间的日光，国民的整体健康状况将得到改善。孩子们将受益匪浅，因为他们中的许多人在天黑后是不被允许出门的。他们将能够在户外玩耍更长时间。据估计，由于能见度更好，英国每年可避免多达100起道路死亡事故；由于人们更晚开灯，可减少约45万吨二氧化碳排放。这对环境有利。对安全有利。对健康有利。这个主意简直让人无法抗拒。我的意思是，听起来太棒了。确实如此。不过看起来，随着你把时间进一步推迟，早晨天就会变得非常黑，对吧？
Oh, 100%. But I mean, just think about all those benefits, right? The argument they always made was like, yes, obviously it would be darker in the morning than we're used to, but the benefits outweigh that one negative part of this. So in 2012, the UK Parliament actually decided to take up this idea and it felt like one of those few things that everybody could agree on. So environmentalist liked it, business leaders liked it, also politically labor politicians were in favor of it and so were the conservatives. Actually it was a conservative MP named Rebecca Harris who proposed launching
哦，百分之百。但是，想想所有这些好处，对吧？他们一直以来的论点是，是的，很明显早晨会比我们习惯的要黑，但好处超过了这一个消极方面。因此，在2012年，英国议会实际上决定采纳这个想法，这感觉像是那种每个人都能达成一致的少数事情之一。环保主义者喜欢它，商界领袖喜欢它，在政治上，工党政客赞成它，保守党也是。事实上，是一位名叫丽贝卡·哈里斯的保守党议员提议发起
this like pilot project for later later, she's the one who put forward the legislation. All political persuasions enjoy the sun. That's the best idea. Yeah. So Rebecca Harris puts it forward about 120 members of parliament say
这个针对“让天黑得更晚一些”的试点项目，她是提出这项立法的人。所有政治倾向的人都喜欢阳光。这是最好的主意。是的。因此，丽贝卡·哈里斯提出了这项议案，大约120名议员表示
they're going to support the bill, polls show it's really popular. It looks like it's just gonna cruise, like it's gonna be a slam dunk once the legislation reaches the house. And it comes up for debate in 2012. And you're setting this up for this not happening. So what actually ended up happening is that members of Rebecca Harris' own party filibustered the bill. Oh, why? Roman, you may be disappointed to hear this, but it's all because of your friends in Scotland. Oh, okay.
他们将支持这项法案，民意调查显示它非常受欢迎。看起来它将顺风顺水，一旦立法提交给下议院，就会轻而易举地通过。它在2012年被提交进行辩论。而你正在为这不会发生做铺垫。所以实际发生的情况是，丽贝卡·哈里斯自己党派的议员对该法案进行了冗长辩论（filibuster）。哦，为什么？罗曼，你听到这个可能会感到失望，但这一切都是因为你在苏格兰的朋友们。哦，好吧。
Let's, I want to hear their take on it because usually me and the Scott C.I. and most things. You're pretty much on the same page always, I think. Roman, I mean, just think about where, like, Scotland is geographically in the UK. So where is it? Like, if you're looking at maps, you can't find a North of England. So they have a different climate from the legislators down in England who are putting this forward. And for them, the idea of having later later mostly means that they're going to have much later sunrises than everybody else.
让我们，我想听听他们的看法，因为通常我和苏格兰人……在大多数事情上。我想你们在绝大多数情况下基本上意见一致。罗曼，我是说，想想苏格兰在英国的地理位置吧。所以它在哪？如果你看地图，你会发现它不可能是英格兰北部。因此，与那些提出这一法案的英格兰南部的立法者相比，他们有着不同的气候。对他们来说，“让天黑得更晚一些”主要意味着他们的日出将比其他所有人都晚得多。
So the whole line was, we're about to have another referendum on Scotland staying in the United Kingdom. And this feels like it is those big, bad politicians down in London making Scotland live a certain way. And this is government overreach. And it's like ammunition for these people who are campaigning for Scottish independence.
所以整体的论调是，我们即将就苏格兰留在联合王国举行另一场公投。而这感觉就像是伦敦那些自大且糟糕的政客在逼迫苏格兰按照某种特定方式生活。这就是政府越权。这就像是给那些为苏格兰独立而奔走的人提供了弹药。
So all of a sudden, there's a couple of MPs who are like, oh, well, the most important thing is we have to make sure Scotland stays in the UK. So that's how we end up seeing a couple of rogue MPs turning on this bill. Roman, have you ever heard of a guy named Jacob Reesmog? No. So Jacob Reesmog is a politician in the UK
所以突然之间，有几个议员觉得，哦，最重要的是我们必须确保苏格兰留在英国。这就是为什么我们最终看到几个叛逆的议员反戈一击，反对这项法案。罗曼，你听说过一个叫雅各布·里斯-莫格（Jacob Rees-Mogg）的人吗？没有。所以雅各布·里斯-莫格是英国的一位政客
who is very perplexed. He's a very prominent person in Boris Johnson's government. He's the house leader. But for our purposes, the reason he's important is because he is a gigantic troll. And Jacob Reesmog came out very much against this bill. The problem with daylight saving bill, as it's called, is it doesn't save any daylight
他对此感到非常困惑。他是鲍里斯·约翰逊政府中一位非常显赫的人物。他是下议院领袖。但对我们而言，他之所以重要，是因为他是一个巨大的“喷子”（troll）。雅各布·里斯-莫格非常明确地反对这项法案。所谓的夏令时法案的问题在于，它并没有节省任何日光
because there's only a limited amount and in the winter, not a lot of it. Not a lot. And I think changing the clocks is a basically fruitless exercise. So Jacob Reesmog, being a giant political troll, decides the best thing that he can do is basically put in a poison pill amendment to try and kill this legislation. So he proposes that Somerset, the area he represents in England, should have its own time zone
因为日光总量是有限的，而且在冬天，日光并不多。真的不多。而且我认为更改时钟基本上是毫无成效的做法。所以雅各布·里斯-莫格作为一个巨大的政治“喷子”，认为他能做的最好的事情基本上就是提出一项“毒丸”修正案，试图扼杀这项立法。因此他提议，他所代表的英格兰萨默塞特郡（Somerset）应该拥有自己的时区
that is 15 minutes behind the rest of the United Kingdom. Oh goodness. And it was this very attention-grabbing idea. Suddenly people weren't talking about daylight saving time anymore. They were talking about this idea of Somerset time. And Jacob Riesmog went on the BBC to explain it and also get like a light ribbing for proposing this idea. The bill comes up for debate and they spent a lot of time talking about
比英国其他地区慢15分钟。哦天哪。这是一个非常引人注目的想法。人们突然不再讨论夏令时了。他们开始讨论这个“萨默塞特时间”的想法。雅各布·里斯-莫格上了BBC来解释这件事，同时也因为提出这个想法而遭到了一番温和的调侃。该法案进入辩论阶段，他们花了很多时间讨论
Scotland, a little bit of time talking about the joke idea in summer set, but in the end, the dissident MPs are able to talk out the bill. Basically, they just debate it long enough that the clock runs out and the bill just dies. So that there's really like a classic filibuster. They like ran out the clock from talking and that exactly that died. So there is sort of widespread support. There's some valid reasons to not,
苏格兰，花了一小会儿讨论萨默塞特的笑话般的想法，但最后，持异议的议员们成功地通过冗长发言拖垮了该法案。基本上，他们辩论的时间足够长，以至于时间耗尽，法案就这样夭折了。所以这确实是一场典型的冗长辩论阻挠。他们通过滔滔不绝地发言耗尽了时间，然后它就真的夭折了。因此，虽然某种程度上存在广泛的支持，但有一些不做的正当理由，
because I'm always on the side of Scotland to tell you the truth. And then there's some invalid reasons to not do it and like this trolley guy. So where are we? Like what are the options now? Well, the UK isn't getting a second time zone. Like, they aren't going to give Scotland its own time zone, which could solve some of these problems. And the government has said
说实话，因为我总是站在苏格兰一边。然后还有一些不做的不正当理由，比如这个“喷子”家伙。那么我们现在在哪？现在有什么选择？好吧，英国不会有第二个时区。比如，他们不会给苏格兰自己的时区，尽管这本可以解决其中一些问题。政府已经表示
they're not taking up the daylight saving issue any time soon. And even if they did implement later later, there's no guarantee, even with all the support that it has, there's no guarantee that it would be popular, because there's something I have been holding back from you, Roman. And that is that the UK has actually tried this before. So during World War II to save energy, they tried switching to double summertime. And I talked to our expert, David Prayer, out about this. And he told me people just really hated the dark mornings. It was considered a wartime measure by a lot of people. A lot of people, especially the
他们不会在短期内处理夏令时问题。而且即使他们确实实施了“让天黑得更晚一些”，也无法保证，尽管有这么多的支持，也无法保证它会受欢迎，因为有些事情我一直对你有所保留，罗曼。那就是英国其实以前尝试过这个。所以在二战期间为了节省能源，他们尝试过改用双倍夏令时。我和我们的专家大卫·普雷尔（David Prayer）谈过这件事。他告诉我，人们只是真的很讨厌黑漆漆的早晨。对很多人来说，这被认为是一项战时的举措。许多人，尤其是
rural people, who again, still had a very large political influence. A lot of them felt it was a very disruptive to their situation and were willing to accept it during the war. You know, once the war was over, they want to get rid of it right away. And that's not the only experiment that hasn't worked. So the UK also tried permanent daylight saving time in the 60s. So they basically didn't change the clocks. They just had the later evenings in the winter.
农村居民（他们依然拥有非常巨大的政治影响力）。他们中的许多人认为这对他们的生活状况造成了极大的干扰，虽然在战争期间愿意接受它，但战争一结束，他们就立刻想要摆脱它。而且这并不是唯一一个行不通的实验。因此，英国在20世纪60年代也尝试过永久夏令时。所以他们基本上没有拨动时钟。他们只是在冬天有了更晚的黄昏。
And people didn't like that. And they switched back. And here's the wild thing, the United States tried it during the energy crisis in the seventh. I had no idea. And people didn't like that either. And every time this happens, despite all the benefits,
而人们并不喜欢这样。于是他们又改回去了。最疯狂的是，美国在70年代的能源危机期间也尝试过。我完全不知道。人们同样不喜欢这样。每一次发生这种情况，尽管有种种好处，
despite saving energy and being better for exercise and saving lives, the dark mornings are the thing that people always complain about. It's really interesting that everyone thinks that they want this new thing, and when they get it, they really hate it. Yeah, and people keep thinking that they'll figure out
尽管能节省能源、对锻炼身体更好、能挽救生命，但早晨天黑一直是人们不断抱怨的事情。非常有趣的是，每个人都以为自己想要这个新东西，可一旦得到了，又真的非常讨厌它。是的，人们一直以为他们能找到
the best way to fiddle with daylight saving, and we have these examples in the United States and the United Kingdom where we've tried something else, we've tried the later evenings, and then gone back to the system that we already have. Right, oh my goodness. And David Prairie, our expert, he thinks the system we have now is pretty good. And he gets why people keep messing with it, but basically all he wants is that people look at
调整夏令时的最佳方法，我们有美国和英国的这些例子，我们尝试了别的方法，尝试了更晚的黄昏，然后又回到了我们原有的系统。对，哦天哪。我们的专家大卫·普雷尔认为我们现在的系统相当不错。他理解为什么人们总是想去折腾它，但基本上他只希望人们能够审视
history and have a better debate about it. At this point, I have a mission to at least try to get states and the federal government, if they're talking about making changes, they make change based on facts and reality and history, and not just on surface knowledge. And if they do that, that's fine with me, because I don't mind whatever they choose, as long as they choose to have to have been considered or the absolute I like him Like from the 99 P.I. School of design Think about what you're doing listen to history know that it can be changed
历史，并展开更好的辩论。在这一点上，我的使命是至少试图让各州和联邦政府在谈到做出改变时，他们的改变是基于事实、现实和历史，而不仅仅是表面的知识。如果他们这样做，我完全可以接受，因为我不在乎他们选择什么，只要他们的选择经过了深思熟虑，或者绝对……我喜欢他。就像来自99%无形设计学院（99 P.I. School of Design）的人一样。想想你在做什么，倾听历史，知道它是可以改变的
Everything's in the continuum, but you just have to think about it. Don't just react. That's that's so good Thank you Chris. Thanks, Robin. Thank you. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Kurt Colestead, Joe Rhodes and Berg, Vivian Leigh, and Chris Baroubaix. Music by our director of sound, Sean Riel. Mixed by Carolina Rodriguez. The Lini Hall is the executive producer, Russ the team, is Riel, mixed by Carolina Rodriguez. The Lini Hall is the executive producer and rest of the team.
一切都处于一个连续体中，但你必须去思考。不要只是做出反应。太棒了。谢谢你，克里斯。谢谢你，罗曼。谢谢。本周的《99%的隐形》（99% Invisible）由库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Kohlstedt）、乔·罗兹和伯格、维维安·李以及克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroubaix）制作。音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。混音由卡罗利娜·罗德里格斯（Carolina Rodriguez）完成。莉妮·霍尔（The Lini Hall）是执行制片人，团队的其他成员还有里尔，混音由卡罗利娜·罗德里格斯完成。莉妮·霍尔是执行制片人，其余团队成员还包括
It's Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Katie Mingle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of this Stitcher and Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can do me at Roman Mars in the show at 9-9-PI-ORC, while on Instagram and Reddit too.
克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉谢马·唐（Lashemadon）、凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我——罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Instagram和Reddit上通过@RomanMars以及节目账号@9-9-PI-ORG找到我。
You can find other shows I love from Stitcher on our website, 9-9-PI-dot-ORC, including Conan O'Brien needs a friend. If you listen to the episode with Will Arnett, you will hear them make fun of 99% invisible. But if you want to listen to or read a bunch more stories about design, look no further. And 99pi.org Hello, it's the tro-clock. It's time to go to the serious XM factory. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站9-9-PI-dot-ORG上找到我喜欢的来自Stitcher的其他节目，包括《柯南·奥布赖恩需要一个朋友》（Conan O'Brien Needs a Friend）。如果你听了威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）作客的那集，你会听到他们拿《99%的隐形》开玩笑。但如果你想听或阅读更多关于设计的精彩故事，无需远求，尽在99pi.org。你好，这是“喷子时钟”。是时候去SiriusXM工厂了。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。